hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a clip titled
monogamy and marriage sex after 10 years
before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers that's a pretty big goal for
the channel and each and every one of
you helps
and just so you guys know this was
submitted by one
of my subscribers on my instagram so if
you guys have any clips you want to send
me
send them to my instagram and follow me
on there
i am not allowed based on our marriage
laws and
the the contract we signed with each
other right to have sex with anybody
else right
so these urges that come i have to share
them with the one person i decide to
spend the rest of my life with
right so that that brings me back to my
my my sound bite okay right
i don't understand and this is what we
can discuss
as a woman because i don't i don't want
to say it's a man versus woman thing but
a lot of women do complain oh my
husband's always on me why is he always
on me
if sex is gonna be a chore for you that
you don't really want to do
why do women constantly push monogamy
on men if you know that you don't want
to have to deal with him all the time
just wanting you
why do you push monogamy on that well
who's to say i pushed anything on
anybody
like well we know that you pushed
monogamy on me i pushed me out of you i
forced you to get married to me
timeout i didn't say you four oh man
oh man she's mad me to get married but
she missed you
say to me that you wanted to be engaged
and you wanted to be married
before you live with me i want a billion
dollars i don't mean i'm gonna get
it i can want something but not you
right now you're dodging the question
nobody pressed you to do it yet
i know what she's trying to say but
she's coming off the wrong way what
she's trying to say is that
he didn't have to marry her she's like i
didn't force you
to like i gave you the choice but i'm
not going to live with you
unless would she say engaged to marry
this is that something i wanted yes it
was
but you didn't impress me are you going
to lie now to the people because we're
you're going to lie now to the people
davao knowing
you didn't want monogamy of course i did
so then why are you avoiding the
question
that's not avoiding the question i'm
saying does that mean because i want it
and i requested that that you were going
to deliver it like nobody pressed you
for that
time you just said you wanted it and
requested it do you not hear yourself
i can make a request see i know exactly
what she's saying she's saying like
that's what i wanted
that's what i requested but you didn't
have to do it
it's just if you wanted to be with me
then yeah you'd have to do it
but there's other girls you could have
you know done other stuff with that's
going to be granted
am i not am i am i not granting you
monogamy you are granting it to me so
this is my question always look at the
boy look at you boy
this is my question oh she's gonna want
defensive
okay why would you want monogamy if
monogamy if if sex
is a chore for you that's the question
you're avoiding the questions i'm not
avoiding the question but at first you
said
me women or or in general me
specifically are
pushing monogamy on somebody okay yes
that's something that i wanted
but i didn't press you for it and be
like devouring the whole a gunshot you
had to propose
so also let me finish also
she's mad i don't feel like i was
adequately prepared
for marriage and i've said that before
because if i knew that marriage and
monogamy was going to involve me
trying to meet you where you were at
sexually for years to come
then i probably would have reevaluated
it if i wanted to be monogamous anyway
so that's fair but we're not even
damn he's like
he's probably like well if you say that
talking about marriage let's even talk
about dating right
okay two people are dating typically
in society who asks for exclusivity
first a woman or a man
i would say a woman thank you that was
my whole point see you were going all
over the place if women
typically ask for exclusivity first then
when they get exclusivity say
he always on me he always want to have
sex why are we asking men for
exclusivity
if we do not want to put okay stds
unwanted like pregnancy oh my gosh
there's a million reasons
people act like just because you have
the urge for something
that you should go along with that
people have urges to to do a lot of
things that they shouldn't do
anticipate it's set for in sex at the
same level as men
we have to think about what that does to
a man
and i don't think that that's being that
conversation is being had
okay i agree and that part i agree with
yes that women are typically the ones
that will ask for the exclusivity
i get that yes but what i'm saying is me
as a woman
i don't think that i was necessarily
prepared or in the mindset to know that
it's almost like
once you get into it then you're like oh
shoot like this is what i'm gonna have
to keep up with
us speaking as 36 year old people know
that now had i known that at 26. i get
that i would have to contend with that
she sounds like she's about to cry i
feel a little bad in the dating realm
then it might have been something i
would have reevaluated so now let's go
back to what you asked me you said to me
you never pressured me
to get married in 2007 we were living
together right
you said you no longer wanted to live
with me and shack up with me
because you wanted to be my wife not my
girlfriend right because i wanted to
know where that don't sound like
pressure to you it sounds like me
voicing where i see my life going
i i understand what she's saying though
she's just saying like
okay if you don't want to get married i
will find someone that
does that's what she was saying and she
said you didn't have to marry me it's
just the requirement to be with me
like as a girl i know what she's saying
but as a guy i could understand how you
would hear that differently
it sounds like me saying this is what i
would like you can decide to meet me
there
if not we can reevaluate what exactly
we're doing okay
what i call it pressure per se not
necessarily pressure
you can tell that they're gonna oh my
god they're gonna get do a fight later
it's pressure but you don't want to say
it's pressure what about
being able to feel pressure what about
being in the game behind it i
said we don't gotta rush to get married
you said i don't want to be engaged
longer than a year
is that not pressure
that's me voicing my opinion about it
sounds like pressure to me so you say
you want to be engaged i get engaged you
say you want to be
married within a year we do that we get
married
then you make it seem like like sex is a
chore to your husband
once again i ask the question
why do women who push forth monogamy
on the man they're dating then get
overwhelmed when that man who tries to
provide that monogamy to you
why do you get upset when we're trying
to be what you want us to be you don't
want me to be with no one else right
right i'm asking this is a serious
question you don't want me to be with no
one else absolutely
so if i decide did all this testosterone
i have i want to give to you
why is this so overwhelming now this is
what you asked for
again damn
damn 26 and 27 year old kadeen
was like okay here's the natural
succession of life
you're graduating because girls have a
quicker timeline than men obviously
because women want to get married and
have kids you're working
you meet somebody you guys are dating
you want children
i want children yes we don't want to
wait too long or too late to have
children
no now a lot of people are waiting until
their 30s to have children and i
understand why
we and we at that time felt like well
we're doing everything
in this natural succession that the
forces that be have given us this
timeline
however i did not realize that after
having children
after you know career changes all of the
turbulences that we've been through in
life
that that was going to have a direct
effect on my sex drive
i also think
that women tend to be like
like men are visual so that doesn't take
as much and women are more like
what do they say women fall in love with
what they hear men fall in love with
what they see
i don't know let me know in the comments
what you guys think who you think was
right in that conversation
do not forget to subscribe trying to get
to 20 000 subscribers i will talk to you
guys
next time